so we got hollywood in a little bit just
now that's okay because our next guest
is one of the most hollywood guys i know
and we see him on talk shows podcasts
we're live on twitch
uh as matt walsh who joins the show how
are you matt great just great to connect
on another uh entertainment program i
prefer twitch icon
ben i don't even know what that is i
barely know what twitch is that was an
education last week
things are good it's hot in the valley
how are you doing well i wonder if
you're sweating it out about who your
starting quarterback's going to be andy
dalton or justin fields are you feeling
confident
with your chicago bears heading into
this season i think it'll be
andy dalton i think they paid money for
him to
teach you know a little bit to the
youngster and also let him transition i
hope they don't pull him out too early
like that's my goal because uh if i'm
them
assess to assess the schedule if we're
eight and eight you know if we're
shooting for eight nader if we're going
to squeak into the playoffs then maybe
throw
trot fields out but i don't see andy
dalton lasting the whole season
i'll be honest you can hear the pain in
matt's voice as a bears fan
and that's the energy and the hope and
the excitement you want going into a
season
well if we're shooting for eight and
eight maybe we'll have this guy
i mean it's been tough being a bears fan
what do you think your lowest moment has
been
as a bears fan in your career oh my god
uh drafting a
canadian football league for our coach
uh a superstar named uh trustman
having him run the program into the
ground that was a low point
i got to experience one of the high
points in recent years uh at soldier
field you know my aunt gene is a
die-hard bears fan she wears a bear's
head on her head when we go to the games
and uh they beat aaron rodgers and the
packers to win the nfc north
when you see what's going on with aaron
in green bay it's got to get you excited
as a bears fan and their chances this
year
yeah it is it's uh he's the number one
bear killer like he
if they have the ball with you know any
time at the end of the game they're
gonna he's gonna get him in field
position and they're gonna squeak one
out
so yeah they're they're the nemesis and
uh
i was lovie smith when he came to town
he said i don't know what's gonna happen
but we will beat green bay and that's
what that's kind of how chicago looks at
their season so
beating green bay is everything uh
especially
with aaron rodgers back there so it's
interesting too because there's no
i don't know like how do you negotiate
with a whole town like that whole town
owns the team so does he have to talk to
the shareholders or like
you i mean there's no like mccaskey to
go hey
let's sit down and iron this out that
could be part of the problem in the
communication breakdown is that he's on
an email
cc'ed with 248 000 people or however
many people who
live in green bay um i own a quarter
share
of the company and i'd like to say
something
matt walsh joins the show two-time emmy
nominated actor from veep and has a new
film with uh eva longoria called
unplugged i remember you telling me the
premise for this and i think it's so
great
share with the class will you because
this is something i think everybody
could uh
benefit from it's basically a couple who
agrees to go on like a digi detox
weekend because their
their marriage is not it's sizzling out
there's something wrong and they're on
their screens too much
they go away to a beautiful remote area
but they
put their screens down and instantly
become paranoid because they don't know
what to do with themselves without
looking at
you know looking things up on google etc
and they become paranoid and
uh freaked out and there's some locals
there who amp up their paranoia and by
the end of it they have to like
get back home without any technology so
it's a comedy and it's uh and i think it
is relevant obviously
when i when i go on i always tease my
wife but when we have a date night i
make her
drive so she can't pick up the phone
i i honestly you know know how it is as
a die hard sports fan uh
like you are in that you're you're
always having access to information
stats things you can look up so it's a
challenge say i gotta log off the
computer at
two in the morning looking up which
running back i'm gonna take in the sixth
round
this is like a real issue that sports
fans my fantasy tight end pull the
hamstring i just have to like
figure this out are you deep in fantasy
leagues now are you getting ready you
have mock drafts happening at the walsh
household
oh my god i wish i was that good i'm the
classic uh
i'm the classic make it to the playoffs
get to the final game
and not win so i get in the true
american sense in our league
i think the winner makes like 1600 bucks
and second place gets like
300 or 400 you know what i mean it's a
classic american you reward first place
and then second place you barely get
your entry fee back
well now's the time in fantasy football
where you know
stakes can be set where if you come in
last there's a punishment or you know
you see leagues going around with
tattoos that
you know go for for losing or winning i
i'm forever immortalized on
west 3rd street here in west hollywood
in goal sports bar for being dead last
in their fantasy league
with a statue but talk to me a little
bit about your fantasy league your crew
any odd traditions with what you guys do
wait hold on don't don't you have a
statue of yourself in a bar
as you came in last it's a statue it has
my name on it it's a crying football
player and it says ben lyons 2019
number one loser or something like that
okay all right i just wanna just in case
i run into that place all right
uh right now the the tradition is you
pay
of course first place gets another like
350 bucks from last place or 200 bucks
but there has been talks of like various
you know punishments or shame like
wearing the ugliest watch in the world
for a year
or uh but it has never come to fruition
we just
it's more about bits and insulting each
other and
you know smack talking basically matt
walsh joins the show
got a new film called unplugged emmy
nodded emmy nominated actor
what's that unplugging it's called
excuse me sorry i was plugged in
i thought it was unplugged it's
unplugging starring eva longoria
producers on it yeah they're on it yeah
no no stone left unturned here at the
rich eisen show
uh you you've started this wonderful
theater out here ucb the upright
citizens brigade
and you've had some wonderful um improv
opportunities with guys like blake
griffin
and other athletes over the years talk
to me about blake the comedian
blake's funny like he's uh
charismatic and funny and gets it as
they say
uh he's great i've worked with a lot of
i actually worked at the globetrotters
too
i used to teach them improv for many
seasons during spring training
i would get to go out to some like
mediocre holiday inn in in the middle of
long island and uh
meet the rookies and sort of teach them
how to commit to the fiction that
they're stepping into
and how to exaggerate you know basic
one-on-one stuff but
uh but a lot of the guys like obviously
the the showman and that
in the the main guy in the globetrotters
they they have chops like they don't
need
to learn anything it sounds like you're
the akemolajuwon
the way that like guys big men go and
learn drop step post moves
bring in matt walsh for the globetrotter
he's gonna teach you how to throw a
bucket full of water that doesn't have
water
we should do that we should start a
school where we help athletes transition
into show business because you obviously
could help with that as well like you're
in the sports world and i could teach a
little improv
and we just we just take but we scout
our athletes but we just start looking
at guys and post game interviews we go
that guy's money no he'll never make it
so we just start recruiting them
and then we just build like a dynasty of
all the best acting
athletes that's what i'm doing right now
watching these milwaukee bucks celebrate
their nba title i'm scouting for our
improv comedy league i think pj tucker
with his uh bottle of champagne and two
natty lights has a bright future
who's the most charismatic guy in that
squad who do you think's gonna
capture the enter the the eyes of
america for the next few years
oh it's obviously the greek free
obviously a great freak but we've been
having a lot of fun celebrating nba
champion bobby portis
who uh at one point uh punched his
teammate when he played for your chicago
bulls now he's getting his name chanted
in milwaukee he's a champion
oh that's awesome you big bulls fan
what's the state of the bulls right now
and in the post-jordan years it's been
kind of tough for you i would imagine in
yeah chicago has but they're rebuilding
and uh there was promise last season i'm
optimistic that
uh they make the playoffs this year
you know that that would be my bold
statement or my hot take
the bulls for whatever reason obviously
the bucks are
amazing but uh i think they squeak in
matt walsh joins the show the movie is
unplugging
we played a little game of celebrity
showdown last week on twitch
got to raise some money for charity you
brought your caddy andy richter
well what's your golfing scene like out
here in la where are you playing who you
playing with you had a nice swing
oh come on uh ben won that match for
anyone who
cares about the stakes of that uh him
and his partner
two million people watched including
some guy named squatting dog on twitch
so they were all excited
was it really two million people that's
crazy
isn't that ridiculous you worked so hard
to have your art shown but you and i
hitting golf balls in a simulator has
two million people named squatting dog
watching
yeah we have two million people now
right listening to this
i i play a lot of the municipal courses
like with
guys like uh richter and uh a bunch of
like comedy writers on scott armstrong
who wrote like uh
old school and uh all those kind of
movies
uh semi-pro uh so in a lot of chicago
like
guys who live out here we play uh kind
of just pick up golf we don't usually
shell out too much money for the nice
courses although you gave me a nice
hot tip on a borrego springs course
which i'm gonna check out when i
when it when it cools down that's right
if you ever wanted to golf on mars this
is the closest thing to it rams hill
down in borrego springs
um it's the only sport you get better at
as you get older i still feel maybe
delusionally so that my best golf's in
front of me it keeps me coming back
yeah for you when it comes to comedy and
continuing to find the joke continuing
to improv continuing to take on movies
we've been talking today about tom
brady's motivation
in year 276 as he's going for his 412th
super bowl
what's your motivation as a comedian as
you continue your career on
i always try to involve myself in
projects where i can influence the
it's going to be comedy drama drama is
not as fun
and uh i try to step into projects where
that are collaborative where i can
influence the comedy either i get to
write it
or pitch ideas to the writers or we we
get to improvise stuff on set
and you know directing a little bit here
and there uh
obviously you get the most influence but
going back to golf i feel like golf is
the one sport
with the most like diminishing returns
because everybody i know every friend
i know i just went back chicago they
were practicing in their yard all summer
and then they
never got better and i feel like any
other endeavor in life
if you spend as much time focusing like
you do on golf
you would have built a guest house or
you would have like built a sailing boat
from scratch you know what i mean like
the hours
that people put in to get better at golf
aren't as fruitful as other pursuits
would you agree with that i agree 100
and i also think it's the only sport you
can watch on television
and watch the best in the world do it
and think to yourself sitting on the
couch
i can do that better the only sport when
you have that feeling sitting on the
couch
you're right because it doesn't look
that athletic it's not like someone's
leaping from the free-throw line and
you know dunking matt walsh joins the
show the movie is unplugging
and you can watch him on twitch playing
golf very soon i'm sure
appreciate you taking the time get
excited for justin fields i know you got
beige water pistol and you're fired up
but
when justin field shows up then things
get serious
oh he's going to be great that's why i
don't want to ruin him i want to like
lay off him
as much as we can and i wonder did you
get to see the new space jam did
do you care about it i'm waiting to take
my niece and nephew i want to go through
uh
childlike eyes and i want to see it
through with their enthusiasm so
hopefully do that coming up why do you
want did you get a chance to go see a
space gym
i like i love lebron lebron fan and i
saw a little bit last night and it
wasn't because the kids had it on
i wasn't drawn in some and they weren't
totally on board but i'll watch it so i
just want to
see what the adults think of space jam
and think of like lebron and the other
act
the nba actors in the movie you know
oftentimes matt when you think of the
great pieces of
a cinema whether it's something in
recent years like roma it's much
much more uh deeper appreciation on the
second viewing so hopefully a deeper
dive on space jam you'll get some of the
nuances that
are throughout the film i'm sure and i
guess if you had to
cast the next space jam three would you
would you go with the greek freak at
this point
oh yeah i mean let's go global let's
let's uh let's get everybody
remarked i mean this guy's the you know
he's gonna listen matt when you when you
have a greek
philosopher from milwaukee telling you
that your ego
is in the past and your pride is in your
future but your presence is your
humility
that sells that sounds like an animated
movie for kids doesn't it
yeah that's a good hero i love that guy
yeah he's pretty he's pretty special
thanks for taking some time man i hope
to see you on a talk show or podcast
soon
yeah nice catching up matt walsh joining
the show die hard bears fan
tempered expectations not not wanting
justin fields out there right i know
i was surprised he's like he said if we
go for eight and eight that'll be great
it just shows you how a bears fan has
been beaten down for all these years
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here